لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
لا لا لا لا
هَاتِ الكَعْكَةَ هَات هَات *** هَاتِ الكَعْكَةَ يَا ثَعْلُوبْ
الكَعْكَهُ لَيْسَتْ مَعِى
أَيْنَ الكَعْكَةَ أَيْن أَيْن ***   أَيْنَ  الكَعْكَةَ يَا ثَعْلُوبْ
الكَعْكَةُ عِنْدَ النَّجَّارْ
أين النَّجَّار ؟
انه هناك
انه في الورشة
لا لا لا لا
هَاتِ الكَعْكَةَ هَات هَات *** هَاتِ الكَعْكَةَ يَا نَجَّارْ
الكَعْكَةُ لَيْسَتْ مَعِي
أَيْنَ الكَعْكَةَ أَيْن أَيْن ***   أَيْنَ  الكَعْكَةَ يَا نَجَّارْ
إِسْأَلُوا عَنْهَا الجَزَّارْ
أين الجَزَّارْ ؟
انه هناك
انه في الدكان
هَاتِ الكَعْكَةَ هَات هَات *** هَاتِ الكَعْكَةَ يَا جَزَّارْ
الكَعْكَةُ لَيْسَتْ مَعِي
أَيْنَ الكَعْكَةَ أَيْن أَيْن ***   أَيْنَ  الكَعْكَةَ يَا جَزَّارْ
إِسْأَلُوا عَنْهَا الخضَار
أين الخضَار ؟
لست أدري
قد يكون في المزرعة
لا لا لا لا
هَاتِ الكَعْكَةَ هَات هَات *** هَاتِ الكَعْكَةَ يَا خضَار
الكَعْكَةُ لَيْسَتْ مَعِي
أَيْنَ الكَعْكَةَ أَيْن أَيْن ***   أَيْنَ  الكَعْكَةَ يَا خضَار
إِسْأَلُوا عَنْهَا الخَبَّازْ
أين الخَبَّازْ ؟
انه هناك
انه في المخبزة
هَاتِ الكَعْكَةَ هَات هَات *** هَاتِ الكَعْكَةَ يَا خَبَّازْ
الكَعْكَةُ سُرِقَتْ مِنِّي
وَ مَنِ السَّارِقْ يَا خَبَّازْ  *** مَنِ السَّارِقْ يَا خَبَّازْ
هو الثَّعْلَبُ المكار
أين المكار؟
هرب من هنا
انظروا انه هناك
لا لا لا لا
هَاتِ الكَعْكَةَ هَات هَات *** هَاتِ الكَعْكَةَ يَا مَكَّارْ
الكَعْكَةُ فِي بَطْنِي
يَا ثَعْلُوبْ السَّرِقَهُ عَيْبْ يَا ثَعْلُوبْ السَّرِقَهُ عَيْبْ
الكَعْكَةُ تُعْجِبُنِي
أَوَتَحْسَبُ هَذَا إِنْجَازْ  *** قُلْ هَذَا لِكِلاَبِ الحَيّ
يا ويلي  النجدة النجدة  يا ويلي   يا ويلي   ااه